I always say that there's this feeling
of one excitement but two kind of
expansion of the mind when you start to
see money come in from something you
built right like that first checker or
that first customer you're like wait a
second I did acts and I received why
like why don't I go to X a bunch of time
so maybe talk about like what like do
you remember what that first sale
actually was yeah my first sale was from
a lady named Audra who ran a fanpage
called women oughta know and it was a
uto she ran her own mechanic like shop
and I created her custom fanpage and I
actually page 34 in the book I put the
screenshot of the invoice it was a $700
invoice you paid me that was my first
ever money were like I felt like I did
it myself but then my wheels all like I
think most really good entrepreneurs are
actually very lazy so they spent a lot
of time I mean I spent a lot of time
thinking about the quickest way to do
things so I can go back to being lazy
what that really means is the quickest
way to do things so then I could fill my
time with things that I wanted to do
right and so I started thinking about
what can I tell Thais this can I hire
someone on Fiverr to do it for a hundred
bucks i mark it up to seven hundred I
started thinking about margins and and
my time and things like that but that
was the first moment a 700 hour check
from Audra I love it and and so I
actually started to do this when at what
point did you say hey look actually I
want to you know write a book about my
experience was that something you knew
you always wanted to do or right out of
the gate or did you actually kind of get
further in the process and then say now
I want to write it
well mr. bone my I think it was 11th
grade English teacher would tell you
this guy Nathan lad has no idea how to
write a thesis paper much less has no
business writing a book because I got I
think maybe a C in his English class in
high school you know the book was the
book was driven because publishers were
putting their their writers on my
podcast and they saw the book volume
that I drove because the Amazon ranked
shot up when I released the interview so
they pressure me to write it because I
know I could sell that's a whole that
was a whole different sort of animal but
like pulling forward from the fan page
stuff I realized the way to make more
money what
to build software to enable Audra to
build her own facebook bandwidth to
drag-and-drop platforms but you know
this world well this was the age of
involve our wildfire vitru buddy media
these drag-and-drop fanpage kind of app
folders and that's the space I played in
my first SAS company heyo comm 8gy Oh
which you know we're asymmetric capital
for we grew at about five million
dollars in sales and I sold it in 2015
to our number-one competitor called vote
ago so that's still live now once I sold
that then I got into the podcasting game
which led to the book got it and so as
you're doing that like why sell the
business right it's growing five million
dollars in sales for most people like a
SAS company would love to get to that
point most kind of die before they ever
get there uh what was kind of a logic or
framework you used and actually still in
the business well it so what he so see
the way I said it
you know we're a center cap what I sold
at five million sales your natural
flowers oh this must have been growing
no no it actually wasn't growing like we
had a massive year in 2012 with about a
million and a half of sales but then
over time each year we were declining
about six to seven percent every year
and one of the biggest mistakes I made
was that that prime year 2012 when vitru
wildfire buddy meeting all these guys
exited for hundreds of millions of
dollars we got a smaller offer it's on
page 243 in the book from eye contact
for six point three million dollars and
I couldn't sell them I wanted to sell
the business I owned 60% of it so that
would put a lot of money in my bank at
21 years old the problem was I had
raised two million from VCS and not a
six point five million our exit on two
million raised was not interesting to
them so they blocked the deal from going
through and so I just kept trying to
build the business but we missed like
with any company like timing is
everything
2012 was the year of Facebook apps we
should have sold that year we declined
heyo steadily year after year after that
we passed five million in sales when you
add up all the sales over the life of
the business which was about four and a
half five years I was 19 to 24 years old
and then sold it in 2015 really add up
pop I caught a discount flash sale I
just wanted to end and move on to the
next thing is my biggest value in life
at that point was not building the
business it was the opportunity cost of
my time no
single can be anywhere you got to do
something bigger than a Facebook fan
page builder